can I ask the the the panel some  questions I want to give you some names  you tell me the likelihood that they're  guilty or not go ahead just do this I'll  be on my opinion okay OJ guilty 100 100  so OJ kill two people straight up and  he's walking around looking for The  Killers too he wrote he wrote he tried  to release the book that said I didn't  do it but if I did this is only because  I loved her very much remember that yeah  you're 100 OJ okay okay so so Cosby  100 he's drunken girls  okay Harvey Weinstein guilty guilty he  did all this right uh Mrs Weinstein I  don't I'm kind of on the I don't know 50  50. 50 50. I don't know but back to  Cosby we're on agreeance that OJ Cosby  and Weinstein are guilty AF